bonjour c'est alain chabat pour brut ce
que je retiens le plus des réseaux c'est
pas du tout lighters c'est c'est plus
c'est plus les trucs marrants en fait je
crois
et encore une fois même later je les
trouve maman franchement il ya des trucs
quand tu te fais tollé la vanne avait
tellement bonne que tu es obligé de dire
si tu viens de me fracasser mais c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
j'ai rien à dire une bonne vanne c'est
une bonne vanne mais je suis pas
beaucoup de compte je suis je suis
parfois enfin par force
de fait les comptes de burger quiz
l'install facebook et twitter et jeu est
en fait on se marre beaucoup à lire
évidemment moi je lis tous les
commentaires
je lis tout comme un comme un
obsessionnel que je suis franchement il
ya des vannes on est un peu jaloux de ne
pas les avoir trouvés
quand on lit des trucs que tu fais
[ __ ] merde a été bonne cette vanne on
aurait dû la trouver il ya des très
bonnes des très bonnes réflexions des
très bons recadrage aussi quand on se
plante sur une sur une question ou des
questions qui se posent par rapport à
une question qu'on a posés et c'est tout
ça donc ça mais je sais pas comment dire
ça mais une bonne heure exigences face à
melen bon une bonne pression je trouve
une pression saine en fait
sinon plus dense et l'incurie pétition
qui apparaît un jour pour demander ce
que gérard darmon et moi-même dansions
la carioca à cannes pour pour le festi
pendant le festival quoi pour les 25 ans
de la cité de la peur voilà c'était ça
la pétition nous fait marrer c'est
rigolo ça et puis au bout d'un moment là
précisé de la pétition pour une telle
ampleur qu'on se sent obligé de le faire
ce qui m'a immédiatement braqué je fais
donc ma tête de con je me dis non a pas
faire ce truc la fin c'est ridicule on
va pas se mettre à danser tous les deux
comme de connard finalement s'appelle
avec gérard darmon et puis je regarde la
pétition je regarde les regarde les
vrais messages déjà en fait que j'avais
pas vu et je regarde les messages et
franchement je les trouve trop mignon et
je trouve ça marrant c'est trop marrant
ce que les gens mettent etc tout ça me
touche et finalement j'en reparle avec
gérard qui avait lui aussi un peu changé
d'avis en regardant tout ça il s'est dit
bon tu vois ça va nous prendre cinq
minutes ça fait plaisir
qu'est-ce qu'il ya toi qu'est ce qui va
se passer allons-y faisons le et donc
voilà
et du coup on s'est repris des cours de
danse parce qu'on avait oublié
évidemment les pas de la chorégraphie et
voilà et on a fait ça pendant une
projection à cannes
t'es pas content parce qu'on avait un
peu nick et j'ai rarement pu y était pas
content on n'avait ni qu'est la corée on
avait bien répéter quand on est arrivé
sur scène franchement olympique
et puis finalement le lendemain on se
dit savoir à ses yeux n'était pas non
plus un concours de danse on n'était pas
la nouvelle star
comme tout le monde il ya un truc que
effectivement que j'aime beaucoup qui
sont voilà le challenge les challenge
quitte le challenge pour des causes me
font pleurer de rire c'est le truc ne
sert à rien si ce n'est si ce n'est aux
gens qui postent en disant voyez j'ai un
bon coeur enfin moi je le vois comme ça
mais j'ai acheté un mauvais fond c'est
pour ça je n'y crois pas une seconde
mais je
mais ça me fait marrer quoi c'est pas
évident de trouver une bonne vanne je
trouve sur ce dolly parton challenge là
le quatrième tender il est chaud à la
fin j'en ai vu plein je trouve que le
meilleur ça reste encore dolly parton
quoi je trouve qu'elle n'a pas été
dépassée encore j'en ai pas vu un qui
m'a fait je me suis plaint mais ça c'est
ça c'est ça c'est très malin et j'en ai
j'en ai vu des très marrant mais il y en
a plein qui sont un peu premier d'oeuvre
du genre je me moque mais en fait je me
vois pas vraiment je fais un peu mon
beau gosse c'est je sais pas comment
dire il n'a pas un qui s'est vraiment
mis dans une position vraiment vraiment
gênante tu dis [ __ ] c'est honteux et
c'est très drôle
je trouve bien pression